beloved canadian musician shawn mendes
dropped a brand new song titled when
you're gone which sees the musician get
candid about his feelings over his
breakup with his former girlfriend
camila cabello prior to dropping the
song sean didn't shy away about his
post-breakup thoughts sharing this
honest video on his instagram i think
that's the reality that kind of hit me
as like oh this i'm on my own now and
now i feel like
finally like i'm actually on my own and
i hate that
[Music]
now sean and camilla called quits in
november 2021 after two years of dating
and although fans were heartbroken over
the senorita powerhouse couple split the
pair assured fans they would remain
close friends sharing the news to their
instagram stories stating we started our
relationship as best friends and will
continue to be best friends now and when
you're gone sean sings from the heart
with the lyrics i hate the thought of
losing you and i didn't know that loving
you was the happiest i've ever been so
it seems there's still a lot of love
between the two
not to mention this song follows
camilla's own breakup track bom bom
which features none other than ed
sheeran he said you hated the ocean but
you're surfing now
of course the breakup songs didn't end
there as back in december 2021 shortly
after the pair announced their split
sean dropped it'll be okay
since their breakup though camila
appeared on apple music one with zayn
low and showed no hard feelings towards
her former boo i love sean and i feel
like
there is literally nothing but love for
him all in all although it's sad sean
will no longer be calling camilla his
senorita at least we have three amazing
songs we got out of it
[Music]